I've come to the end of my Cambodian
Odyssey I've eaten dishes that were
nearly lost for good under Khmer Rouge
rule it's delicious and delicacies born
from necessity my adventure has taken me
to some of the remotest places I've ever
been
now I'm back in poor Phnom Penh to cook
my take on traditional Cambodian food
for royalty alongside one of the
country's top chefs the world dinners
been held on a hundred and eighty foot
Imperial barge that's gonna be sailing
up the Mekong River
Thank You Olli I'll be cooking with lou
meng' he runs one of Cambodia's best
restaurants No so it's very exciting
cooking for all family is it stressful
yes it was we need to make it perfectly
the meal tonight he's trusting me to
cook half the dishes on the traditional
menu his food is some of the best in the
country and I need to reach his high
standard he's gonna raise the bar
silently my [ __ ] together big time
because I can't fully make myself look
stupid
okay so how are you I'm fine earlier in
the week I met sir Pekka pnom Penn's
amazing catering school for street kids
and he's so impressed me I asked him to
come along and be my sous chef tonight
look at you I'm so proud of me you know
that look you look like a pro we're
cooking for Cambodia's most important
VIPs our ol party of two princesses and
a prince and my country mentor katana is
on board too
as soon as the boat gets underway sir
Peck and I get down to work my menu is
inspired by the revival of traditional
Cambodian dishes I've tasted on my trip
a version of fish amok a Cambodian curry
and my take on the jungle dessert have a
little taste for this we got this from
the beehives in mono Carrie do you fit
for a princess hmm nice my dish is gonna
be served to royalty side by side with
Lu Ming's
so they have to be perfect I'm starting
with my version of amazing amok dish
Katara taught me at the beginning of my
week lu ming is watching every move and
i've made a mistake with the first step
the classic cambodian spice paste just a
little bit to start finding up i tried
to salvage it in the blender
simplicity said wasn't holding so
separating so took it off last minute
and blended it I had no choice
please organize I mean he's doing
dezzy's sweated yet so he's you know I'm
adding the salvage paste to a Cambodian
freshwater fish called snakehead and
praying the mixture will souffle the
guests are sitting down and they're
expecting faultless Cambodian cuisine
you give me a time first day before you
give me time and I'll tell you if I can
match it yes yep if blue is fast ahead
of me then
tough [ __ ] they'll have to wait lumens
beef kebabs and lemongrass skewers look
great as they go out and they're hitting
the spots beef is very good
delicious the taste is only good and the
presentation also is lovely now it's
down to me to deliver thankfully the
souffle has risen like katanas but what
will she make up my amok compared to
what we used to cook we're more souffle
like very light and this one a little
bit more heavy after guitar of lukewarm
reaction I need to pull out all the
stops with my next two dishes I'm
determined not to let Liu Ming down a
little bit of salt and salt good next
course I'm doing a Korean spy bus
effects teacher at the cookery school
I'm sitting the pumpkin to give it a
luxurious taste and using chicken
instead of pork the balance of flavors
is crucial I'm adding fish sauce for
saltiness and depth it's been served
with new men's exquisite aromatic rice
wrapped in turmeric leaves and I'm
feeling confident very surprised if this
doesn't go down a storm honestly it's
got that sweet spicy 50/50 on the bump
salùte asleep
I would say they're happy see this money
my career has been served to the wrong
party princess Awad Tessa and princesses
marry young and bought pas de vie but
have I done enough to justify looming
faith in me it was melting in my mouth I
loved it and I think also some guests
loved it as well just as I've managed to
pull it back by a problem with my last
dish the jungle inspired honey and rice
dessert so the choices are getting this
set now is gonna be very very honest and
the pressure has got to me as blooming
Jasmine mousse where's the diner's my
reputation is hanging in the balance in
the 35 degree heat the rice has barely
set
my jungle dessert is my last chance to
WoW the wrong party I'm praying and not
too soft I've got to send the mouse
[Music]
this excellent is surprised me
I would think here's an employer cook
he's a better cook than my cook cook at
home I would hide in any time it's been
a hell of a night serving my twist on
traditional Cambodian dishes side by
side with one of the country's best
chefs was a real tester that I've
experienced somebody bringing the
cuisine from the countryside back to a
city we have our own regional cooking
and we don't know how to develop that
and I think golden show us tonight how
it can be done I only just held my own
but I'll be forever grateful to lu ming
for the opportunity he's given me
tonight it was an honor to be in the
kitchen and I've had the most
extraordinary week
kotone told me get out of town get off
the beaten track and get into the
countryside you'll be amazed and I was I
was amazed and shocked at the same time
the civil war the Khmer Rouge no one's
had to deal with that level of crap and
then start clawing back their roots and
wanting to put stake in the ground
because they can produce bloody good
food
I'm leaving Cambodia with a vast amount
of knowledge and I'm gonna tuck that
away and use it to great use
[Applause]